rocky it is time for this week's pet
project lori hearing joins us from the
nspca and she brought along someone who
needs a safe and caring home a cat named
cyrus hey lori what a cutie in your lap
tell us a little bit about cyrus hey
mercedes this distinguished gentleman is
cyrus and as you can tell he's very
friendly and very sweet he's purring he
is a 14 year old gentleman he would be a
great fit for pretty much any home
that's watching this afternoon he's
great with other cats he's great with
kids he um
does require a little gabapentin for his
arthritis
to keep him comfortable and he did come
into our shelter d quad now while we
certainly don't condone in any way
decline at nevada spca it's how he
showed up and you know mercedes he came
with a sister and his sister's already
been adopted so we need to make sure
that cyrus gets a home very soon i love
how you refer to him as this gentleman
is that kind of his demeanor just very
low-key kind of uh maybe lazy not the
most active of lifestyles
it is he's um as you can tell he has
more than a touch of gray and you know
at 14 he would qualify for our senior
for seniors program at nevada spca so we
would waive the fees for cyrus for any
human senior over the age of 65
and he has a lot of life left in him and
would be a great companion for anybody
that's watching you today a great lab
cat and again would get along with other
cats would get along with
children in that in your family and
would be a great addition to almost any
family that's watching right now he is
adorable and lori thank you for
everything that you guys do there if
you're interested in adopting a pet go
to nevada nevadaspca.org
or call them at 702-873-7722